hello everyone and thanks for attending
this presentation on drug testing and
regulatory monitoring my name is John
Fuhrman and I am the director of
Washington health professional services
or W HP S & W HP s is the Washington
state regulatory alternative to
discipline substance use disorder
monitoring program for nurses I'll talk
a little bit more about what that is and
in later slides very briefly however
I've also been very involved in the
regulatory occupational health landscape
for a long time I've been in this
position now for about eight years and
prior to coming into this position I
work for the Washington State OSHA
program writing statute and rule in
regards to the occupational health realm
so that's just a little background on me
so let's start with the presentation
drug testing the regulatory monitoring
drug testing is an important tool in the
regulatory and legal monitoring of
individuals with substance use disorder
and/or work and safety sensitive
positions such as healthcare providers
and airline pilots due to the legal and
personal ramifications of a positive
drug test this type of testing also
known as forensic drug testing it's
conducted under strict structure and
multiple redundancies and checks
regulatory drug testing now commonly in
cubes includes the use of panels that
include ten or more drug classes and
this is in contrast to what was done
just a little while ago several years
back when most commonly what was termed
the night at 5:00 panel was used for
most regulatory and workplace monitoring
and that includes drugs and drugs
classes such as amphetamines cocaine
marijuana opiates and psilocybin
offensive siding PCP well more regularly
now and our type of monitoring forensic
monitoring at least 10 and maybe 15
drugs or drug classes are used and you
may have noticed in that list I just
gave things like alcohol which is
surprising is not included and also
classes such as benzodiazepines or [ __ ]
weights and other things now that we
regularly test for such as MDMA or
ecstasy and depending on the situation a
program may want to include
over-the-counter drugs such as such as
dextromethorphan or also other
substances such as crack kratom
metabolites so I do want to say before I
go any further that I have no conflicts
of interests or disclosures and the
objectives of this presentation are to
identify the characteristics of forensic
drug testing and the differences between
forensic and medical drug testing which
we'll go over briefly be able to follow
the path of testing from collection to
reporting also called the chain of
custody and identify the role of the
medical review officer and result
determination an important takeaway from
this presentation is the realization
that a drug test in and of itself cannot
definitively tell whether one has or has
not misused a drug or answer the
question of impairment it only
establishes a probability of use the
Medical Review officer along with other
investigatory and evaluation tools
complete the picture and help to develop
an action plan going forward so a drug
testing regulatory and workplace drug
testing end or forensic drug testing as
it's called under an umbrella really
became more commonplace during the
Vietnam War
when it was used as a preventative tool
and also to screen soldiers coming back
from war and allowing them to enter into
the workplace and specifically enter
into the workplace and positions that
were safety sensitive and then in 1989
the Department of Transportation issued
drug testing regulations and six
transportation industries
these include industries such as
Airlines locomotive and commercial
driving so what drove this in addition
to the more commonplace and military I
guess push the start forensic drug
testing or events such as a fighter jet
crash that occurred on the US Nimmons in
1981 in which fourteen were killed and
an Amtrak train crash outside of
Washington DC and 1987 and which 16 were
killed other industries with employees
and safety sensitive positions ie health
care now test and refer employees with
substance use disorder for structured
monitoring with the opioid epidemic and
healthcare medication diversion cases
some resulting in blood-borne pathogens
outbreaks regularly appearing in the
news the National Council of State
Boards of Nursing and the Federation of
physician health programs published
guidance on the monitoring of health
care professionals with substance use
disorder and almost all states of
structured regulatory monitoring
programs in place for health care
professionals in addition with the
advent of drug courts and other
diversion type programs forensic drug
testing is becoming more and more
ingrained in our society so what does
forensic drug testing forensic drug
testing and what does it do it
establishes abstinence it supports and
documents recovery it monitors the
effect of the effectiveness of a
treatment plan or
during plan it establishes adherence
from drug use attracts deviations so for
an example in the case of marijuana or
THC and testing for THC the windows of
section can be very long months in some
cases due to its fat silence liability
so you may want to track THC levels over
time to determine whether someone is
remaining absence abstinent as those
levels will increase over time and it's
also very useful forensic drug testing
and legal and criminal investigations so
what's the difference between forensic
and medical testing well forensic
testing you know provide excuse me
provides the benefits as described and
medical testing is most typically done
to diagnose and treat emergency room
patients it's becoming increasingly used
in opioid pain management program
programs in psychiatry to confirm
medication adherence and therapeutic
levels and to make decisions that affect
other aspects of a patient's care it
also prevents dangerous medication
interactions
however realize that sometimes there's
an overlap between forensic and medical
or clinical drug testing for example
when a pregnant woman tests positive for
an illicit drug this may be not all this
may not only affect the patient's care
however may also trigger a mandatory
report to legal authorities so again it
is important to know what you are
testing for and why as even in clinical
settings a forensic testing approach may
not only be useful but legally and
ethically necessary so some of the
aspects of forensic drug testing are
required shape chain of custody tracking
required confirmation testing it's used
for the provision of legal science
big evidence the donor must consent to
the test and it's more expensive than
medical drug testing the one important
consideration of forensic drug drug
testing is cost forensic tests because
paddle size chain-of-custody
confirmation testing the use of observed
collections and Medical Review officer
review can be substantially more costly
than clinical testing caution should be
taken to choose only necessary panels
and tailor testing schedules to maximize
cost benefits also a forensic drug drug
testing frequently uses cut-off levels
to lessen the probability of action
being taken in response to extraneous
exposures well talk more about this in a
bit so first off choosing a laboratory
is very important look for a laboratory
that has expertise in drug testing and
addiction treatment settings or
regulatory standards the use of a
toxicology laboratory is preferred the
Department of Health and Human Services
publishes a list of laboratory certified
to be mandatory federal workplace drug
testing program standards and when
testing under federal guidelines or
federal regulations those laboratories
are required and in general cap Samsa
and CLIA or CMS Centers for Medicaid and
Medicare services servic certifications
are preferred before selecting a
laboratory practitioners should contact
the laboratory and regulatory programs
should contact the laboratory and speak
directly to the director toxicologist
you may also want to visit the
laboratory determine the laboratories
analytic capabilities do they test
outside of the night of five that I
mentioned earlier and are they able to
tailor panels as appropriate do they new
conformation testing
what is that what does that entail for
that laboratory inquire about other
panels that test for drugs and drug
classes as confirmed that the laboratory
follows established federal guidelines
and certifications and determine whether
the laboratories testing procedures are
appropriate for friends accuse ensuring
that the laboratory provides technical
assistance so the practitioner and the
regulatory program can obtain help with
interpreting test results or determining
which panel to order so commonly use
samples or matrices are urine urine is
by far the most common sample type used
it has been evaluated more thoroughly
than the other samples types and is the
most common sample type tested so
there's much more experience with Europe
drugs of choice and detection window
knowledge is necessary when using your
animal urine but the other matrices also
hair here provides at generally a
three-month detection window and the
reason for that is it can be checked
outside of that three-month window but
in most cases the laboratory runs our
test a three month sample or growth
sample of hair what is generally used to
detect recent use for example in traffic
stops and non regulatory or workplace
drug testing scenarios however however
health testing phosphatidyl ethanol
which is a alcohol metabolite is
frequently used to detect alcohol use in
three to four week windows now is
similar to hair both our care keratin so
for the most part the detection windows
are similar similar however no
ignorance so is a better base or
collecting collector for drugs in most
cases saliva is a non-evasive directly
observed collection that has a reduced
risk of adulteration and in some cases
ate is able to detect same they use big
negative with saliva at least at this
point as that it provides reduced
detection windows and has a smaller
research or experience history now I
didn't mention breath breath usually is
not or let you use as a majors and
patrons and regulatory monitoring but is
a point-of-care testing alternative that
can be used so observed versus
unobserved collections on federal
collections require that all collections
be directly observed and it's the
preferred preferred method and all
regulatory monitoring programs and
prevents substitution dilution and
adulteration or it it ensures to a great
degree that those are prevented but
requires direct observation of the urine
stream not just someone standing in the
room with the donor unobserved testing
can be done and it may be necessary what
some gender on third when the same
gender observer is not available use of
a dry room is necessary and in that case
and whether it's observed deflection is
observed or unobserved must be
documented on the chain of custody for
so dry room collections require turning
the water off on the taps and adding a
gluing agent to the toilet tank to avoid
sample dilution not providing hand soap
in the restroom where the sample is
being collected not storing cleaning
agents in the restroom for example
ammonia containing products bleached oil
products etc and not allowing coats
purses or bags into the restaurant with
the patient one thing that comes up from
time to time is the shy bladder syndrome
effect and when an individual says they
cannot provide a observe sample this is
not acceptable and may require the donor
to assume liquids over a several hour
period in order to eventually provide
that sample low chain-of-custody
chain-of-custody is the documentation of
the trail of custody control transfer
and analysis of a drug sample both the
der donor and collector confirm the
sample collection time collection
procedure and samples seal any deviation
invalidates the sample all of this is
documented on the chain of custody form
the chain of custody process protects
the integrity of the sample a test
result and allows for a legal defense
for federal dog drug testing the use of
the federal drug test in custody and
control form is mandatory and legal
cases all persons handling persons
handling the sample package may need to
be identified across the custody line
and regulatory monitoring or most Rancic
testing only collection and receipt at
the laboratory may need to be tracked
and documented the window detection is
the range of time that a substance can
be detected or a drug can be detected in
a sample it reverse both to the time to
detection and time to clearance it's
time to be metabolized eliminated or
excreted so each matrix or sample type
and drug has a different window of
detection ranging from minutes to months
so what can effect that with no
detection chemical properties of the
substance individual metabolism rates
and excretion arouse proud of drug
administration frequency of use and
about of the substances guested selected
cutoff concentrations the individuals
health diet way
gender etc so the window of detection
while gentlemen generally established it
is not set in concrete and the
regulatory program must have additional
information as I just listed in order to
make determinations in regards to a drug
test result
so all sample matrices may show the
presence of both parent drugs and their
metabolites drug metabolites usually
remain in the body longer than new the
parent blood and oral fluids are better
suited for detecting the drug uranus
most likely to contain the drugs
metabolites an example is for cocaine
most commonly its metabolites benzo L
ago 9 as is tested for so one must make
sure that they're not looking at a
cocaine window of detection but work
you're looking at the metabolite window
of detection so this slide just gives
some examples of detection windows that
are most commonly used in regulatory
monitoring programs alcohol or ethyl
alcohol generally 10 to 12 hours now
there is another test of metabolites
test ethyl glue goron ID or ATG that has
a window of detection that is 2 to 3
days so again make sure you know what
you're testing for cocaine I've talked
about that already and feta means
usually one to two days with chronic you
seven days by a szczepan to seven days
but its metabolites nor diazepam 6 to 24
days and cannabis th-th-the is usually
tested for its one three days and casual
use but it can be thirty days or longer
with chronic use and again depending on
the individual if the individual is
heavyset that window of detection may be
pushed out longer and also on depends on
the cutoff level use a lower cutoff
leveled more likely will result in the
presence of drug or drug metabolites
during a longer detection period and
also be aware again of the matrix being
used or the sample so for hair and nail
I usually wait up to 10 days if I'm
looking for recent use to allow that
hair to grow out sufficiently to be able
to provide a a result that's valid for
use that recent use one easy way is to
use to use Windows of detection again
this is a very easy way but just to have
it in the back of your head is the rule
of threes Brent can look back
approximately three hours you're in
three days ads in the blood for three
weeks and hair and fingernails up to
three months and as I said earlier
saliva testing windows ranged from 1 to
48 hours versus back 3 days or 72 hours
for four year and because because most
laboratories analyzed an amount of hair
equivalent to three months growth that's
why that three-month detection would
look usually use for her hair and also
fingernails which are similar matrices
so cut-off levels cutoff levels
determine whether a test is positive or
negative
using the cutoff level prevents a small
trace of a drug as resulting in a
positive drug test it takes into
consideration possible passive exposures
and lower cut-offs are established when
testing populations for testing
populations that approach to drug and
cutoff level with a specific drug is the
point of measurement or above which a
result is considered positive below
which a reasonable is considered
negative this level is established on
the basis of the reliability and
accuracy of the test and its ability to
detect the drug or metabolites for
period attributes these levels are
at high enough to detect concentrations
ingesting drug abuse however as I said
in regulatory mining monitoring since we
are not dealing with a general
population or a general workplace
population but one that is pursued or
identified to have substance use
disorder or misuse those cut-offs are
generally set a little bit lower
confirmatory testing is required for all
regulatory and forensic testing usually
a presumptive test a point-of-care
immune immunoassay type test is
originally done to detect the
presumption of a drug or its metabolites
in the substance and then the use of a
high sensitivity and specificity
specificity testing is then done to
confirm the presence and quantity of
specific drugs metabolites gas or liquid
liquid chromatography combined with mass
spectrometry is preferred and then
certifying scientists confirm each
positive an addition validity testing is
done for all positive samples and in
many cases negative samples and validity
testing as creatinine levels specific
gravity pH also temperature may be the
presence of oxidative ad agents such as
bleach to confirm that yes and B this is
a valid human sample samples are
considered dilute or invalid Munir and
creatinine is below twenty milligrams
per deciliter and a specific gravity
less than one point zero three so in
forensic testing split samples are
required and I say required as as mostly
applied to urine samples in some cases
I'm aware of laboratories that do not
require us but samples of blood let's
say samples are
to the donor as the a sample is
generally used for testing and then the
B or the split sample is then held for
positive tests generally up to one year
and that split sample then can be used
at request of the donor earned some
claims cases legal authorities to
determine whether or not or determine
the strength of that original positive
or negative it provides the option for
an independent re-evaluation of the
result and in most cases it is a truly
independent evaluation because the split
sample or that B sample is sent to a
second objective laboratory for analysis
testing schedules are important random
testing is preferred day limitations may
be necessary due to collection site
access so a random a true random
schedule would include you know seven
days a week testing but in many cases
it's limited to five Monday through
Friday because of collection site access
so frequency should be determined by
individual circumstances ie the ability
to pay such safety sensitive work and
patient acuity consider test detection
abilities and windows and detection as
discussed and testing frequency may be
decreased over time and in line with
recovery stage
the Medical Review officer is a very is
a very important part of the regulatory
monitoring monitoring and or forensic
drug testing team simply put and
explained by the US Department of
Transportation a medical review officer
as a person who is a licensed physician
and who is responsible for receiving and
reviewing laboratory results generated
by an employer's drug testing program
evaluating medical explanations for
certain drug test results the Medical
Review officer has been termed as the
gatekeeper or advocate for the accuracy
and integrity of the drug testing
process medical review officers provide
Quality Assurance review for the drug
testing process determine if there's a
legitimate medical explanation for
laboratory confirmed drug test results
the MRI reviews laboratory processes
chain of custody documentation
interviews the donor collects collateral
I mean donor medications and among other
processes to determine the validity and
strength of a test result EMR Medical
Review officer recommends follow-up
actions to include additional testing
and/or collection site training the
Medical Review officer is an essentially
important element of any forensic and
regulatory monitoring drug testing
program as the Medical Review officer
provides objective legally defensible
program oversight the medical review
officers opinion will anchor legal
decisions which will be represented to
court as expert testimony so it's
important to take away that a positive
drug test is not sufficient evidence or
a diagnosis of a substance use disorder
or non-compliance with a regulatory
monitoring contract or agreement it does
not explain whether a patient's symptoms
or donor symptoms are caused by the
presence of a substance in most cases a
drug test does not measure impairment
and in most cases it test does not
measure patterns of use over time
they'll be very
cautious when interpreting a drug test
use your laboratory resources use your
certifying scientists resources use your
medical review officer to make a final
determination as how to act on a drug
test result
so regulatory monitoring and recovery to
ramp up the purpose of regulatory legal
monitoring is to use practical evidence
based structures for the evaluation
treatment and management of individuals
substance use disorder public protection
is at the core of any monitoring program
and it is in the best interests of the
program and stakeholders to have a
strong legally defensible drug testing
process while this presentation focused
on forensic drug testing as stated by
the National Council of State Boards of
Nursing evidence shows that approaching
addictions as a treatable illness is
highly effective financially and has
broader positive societal impacts one
scientific tools are tailored to meet
individual needs and individuals are for
early-modern monitored the public can be
assured they're being provided
appropriate and safe services so thank
you very much for your attention and
time there's my contact information feel
free to contact me at any time if you
have questions about this presentation
and here are is a list of the primary
resources used for this presentation
thank you very much